une matinée sportive entre frère et
soeur mélanie et julien se sont lancé un
challenge participer à une course de 10
km le plaisir de courir pour cette
fratrie originaire de villepreux bagnon
sera traîné un petit peu mais
franchement une fois par semaine à peu
près voilà on fait pas partie d'un club
donc c'est plus de loisirs j'ai trouvé
une source de motivation aussi avec ma
soeur donc on a déjà couru plusieurs
fois ensemble c'est vraiment très sympa
mélanie et julien font partie des 200
aux coureurs qui ont pris le départ du
10 km une boucle de 5 km à parcourir
deux fois à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur
de la ville
c'est un mix de durban et 2
on va dire de trade donc on a on a des
parcours sur terre donc qu'on tourne
essentiellement ville propre avec un
premier tour réalisé en 18 minutes 42
adrien grappille remporte cette course à
la maison en 38 minutes 30 pour le ville
provient cette cinquième participation
aura été la bonne il devance de 30
secondes
emmanuel prix bas c'est mon premier
podium et donc dans ma ville ça fait
vraiment super plaisir je connais c'est
à peu près le parcours et je savais où
faire la différence
de leur côté mélanie et julien ont
terminé la course en une heure et six
minutes
or doute pas s'arrêter là pour motiver
parce que ces tests éprouvant surtout la
deuxième le deuxième tour la l2 côte là
qui nous ont bien la classe d'ailleurs
l'objectif c'était qu'on arrive en même
temps à la course à la à l'arrivée donc
voilà on sait attendu chacun a pendant
un trajet pour l'édition 2018 de la
ville proviennent les organisateurs
réfléchissent à une nouvelle course de
15 km et peut-être un jour proposer un
semi marathon